it's true
gays are converting your children
through cartoons
and it looks like lesbians are leading
the charge
[Music]
hey there folks so
this is one of those times where i just
kind of noted something myself and then
dug a little bit more into it now it's
been in my head and now you get to have
it
so
i am going to give some numbers to back
up my assertion here but
am i the only one who has felt like
as much as we are now getting some very
good
lgbtqia plus representation in animated
entertainment particularly those aimed
at families
it seems to be leaning very heavily
on
female queer representation
namely i'm thinking
lesbians or female bisexuals that's not
to say that
gay men or bisexual men are completely
absent but it feels like they're
relegated to background
supporting
rarely leads and possibly less common in
the first place now like i said i am
actually going to back this up with some
amount of research and some amount of
data now a couple of things about the
parameters that i am using for what i'm
talking about here now
thing number one i am only looking at
american television today i don't have
the spoons to try and parse japanese
especially because i don't know enough
about the culture to deal with all the
queer rep and anime and things like that
so we're not dealing with it we're
dealing with american animation here
secondly we are dealing with animation
aimed at a family audience so anything
intended for an adult audience so that's
your simpsons your family guy your south
park a whole bunch of stuff that's on
netflix these days
that is not what i'm talking about i
want to take a look at the
representation that has basically been
deemed safe or appropriate
for a younger demographic to consume the
other thing that i want you to be aware
of and this one i'm putting my foot down
hard on this
i am only taking into consideration
confirmed
in
canon within the show itself
that these people
are gay or lesbian or some form of queer
now i am focusing on gay and lesbian
there'll be some mention of bisexual i'm
not dealing with gender identity in this
one i do at some point want to take a
look at gender identity representation
in family media but that's not what i'm
doing today
so
again to reiterate we're looking at
american shows aimed at families and
confirmed
in show i don't want to hear
about a creator a writer a director a
voice actor whatever confirmed that this
character is gay or lesbian or what i'm
not counting that
i
am not going to deal with that because
you cannot count on the audience ever
becoming aware of that if they become
heavy fans yes they'll probably find
that out but i am dealing with the
knowledge that people who watch the show
and only the show whatever that show may
be
are they going to know
that this is a lesbian gay bisexual etc
character
and if the answer is
no or it's implied or you could read it
that way
i'm not counting it okay
all right so when i was looking at this
to try and spot some trends or patterns
i only went back so far i went back to
about the mid-2000s which was where from
what i could find we started getting
some confirmed instances because you can
find lists and stuff of characters
that'll list shows from the 90s but
again almost all of that falls under the
category of confirmed by creators after
the fact so it's already disqualified by
the parameters that i laid out and to be
clear that's not necessarily criticism
especially stuff back in the 90s you
really couldn't
get away with it in the vast majority of
cases it was implied was all we were
going to get so that's why i'm looking
at stuff more recent especially because
it feels like there's been a surge in
the past decade or so of this kind of
representation which i do feel is a good
thing and i also should cop to the fact
that i have not watched every show i'm
going to reference so while i did my
best to do my research on this i
am human and fallible and
i did
pretty much limit this primarily to
shows that i would consider mainstream
now that is going to be partially my
bias if i looked at lists and saw shows
that i had never heard of on channels or
streaming services that i hadn't didn't
hear about
i was really hesitant to include it here
now
that is again pushing my bias but i'm
trying to think this i'm concerned
mostly with mainstream
representation here if it's this niche
thing on this niche streaming surface or
this web series that only people who are
definitely okay with this are ever going
to find that doesn't really work for the
purposes i'm talking about and where i'm
ultimately going to be going with this
because yes i do kind of have some
points to make once we get through
running all the numbers and i did trying
to stretch outside of the stuff that i
definitely knew myself like i looked at
a whole bunch of lists of from various
sources of oh here's all the
representation in these shows and this
but you know what the vast majority of
it got eliminated on the under the
criteria that i already listed the big
one being it's only implied in episode
but that still gave me some stuff that i
haven't seen but i tried to do my
research on and here
is what i have found this is not
comprehensive i'm going to be citing
examples not complete statistics because
again i don't have the capacity to do
that and what i
found was basically what i said at the
opening
a heck of a lot more representation
prominently for primary or secondary
characters for
female queer representation and far less
for male
and with the male representation it was
much more likely to fit into certain
rigid structures that i will come back
to actually you know what i thought i'd
come back to that i'm just going to lay
it out now and i'll dig into why i think
this might be later
there's an awful lot of gay dads
there's a lot of gay adults
not a lot of gay youth and like i said
dads seems to be the go-to
default here so just to cite examples of
both lesbian characters and gay
characters let's get into some instances
you have shows like 16 which had connie
who was a recurring lesbian drummer
character star versus the forces of evil
had jackie lin voltron had a number of
gay male characters there was some
issues with a barrier gays trope but
that's a different conversation you have
things like the loud house which
actually has a fair amount of stuff
there's luna and sam which is a lesbian
couple howard and harold gay dads more
recently there's things like the owl
house with luce and amity and also what
appears to have been a relationship
between a female and a non-binary
character she-ra holy cow okay there's a
lot here there's catra and adora there's
spinarella and natasa there's scorpio
and perfuma and then there's bo's dads
there's also kyle and rogelio to be fair
um confirmed at the very very
last possible second in the show
adventure time marceline princess
bubblegum summer camp island gay ghost
dads my little pony friendship is magic
has two confirmed lesbian couples but
the only male queer character supposedly
bisexual is a word of god instance where
creators said it it's not confirmed in
the show there's a show called okay ko
let's be heroes which actually has a
really healthy mix kind of across the
board that's i would say one of the
exemplars as far as really having a good
spread of representation goes ducktales
has indian thai gay dads pete the cat
gay dads dragon prince a male father
figure guess what yeah he's gay so
effectively gay dads bravest knight rare
instance of the lead character being gay
but he's also a gay dad gravity falls
they're not dads but they are adults and
while not competently so they are
authority figures steven universe has a
ton of stuff but pretty much all lesbian
or non-binary in one way shape or form
the only apparent exception being the
characters of harold smiley and quentin
frowny
which is unconfirmed in the show and
another word of god instance so we're
looking at a pretty good spread of
female lesbian characters as leads as
secondary characters who are peers and
contemporaries of the league character
so we are meant to relate to them in the
same way that we are meant to relate to
the main characters whereas gay men
are getting relegated much more often to
background
father figure
authority figure
tertiary character
there's some distance
there
they're not generally being presented as
upfront in the same you are meant to
relate directly to these characters way
as lesbians seem to be now this is not
completely devoid of examples there are
shows like people in the age of the
wonderbeast which have benson and troy
benson being one of the primary
characters on the show so
there is some but this kind of feels
like the exception that proves the rule
the question this leaves if you are
willing to accept what i've given you so
far again not as definitive absolute
proof but i think an indication of
trends
why
now much like when i talk about why
certain tropes or trends persist or go
the directions that they do i don't
believe this is anything intentional or
deliberate or anyone's master plan
this is just a thing that happens
but there are still reasons for it and i
think there's a couple that while i
cannot definitively say are the cause
for this they seem to me to be likely
suspects
firstly if we're going to be completely
honest
historically
gay men have been
demonized in a bit more of a specific
way than lesbians now that is not me
trying to undermine the ways in which
lesbians have been demonized across
decades and centuries but my point being
generally it was far more likely
for
gay men in
anti-lgbtq plus sentiments
to be depicted as predatory especially
towards young boys
you didn't get that as much with
lesbians lesbians were much more often
framed more as
women who lost their way
as opposed to being actively dangerous
and indoctrinating
which was much more common to be the
framing of gay men now we have
largely not completely but largely as a
society moved on from that but the thing
is
when a trope or a stereotype persists
for long enough it takes a long time to
shake off and if i'm gonna be completely
honest
i'd be willing to bet that on a gut
level
there's still a sense of discomfort
around having gay men specifically in
children's media because that feels more
dangerous than lesbians
which might be an indication as to part
of the reason why we see so many gay
dads because if they are dads
they are adults who have to be in some
kind of stable point in their life
and they're in a committed relationship
and
since they are usually parents of
characters we know if that character
seems to be okay and we meet their gay
dads we're able to make an immediate
assumption oh they raised this character
perfectly fine so now we can trust them
but without that framing in place and
like i said it comes up
disproportionately often
that leaves the door open
for those thoughts
to worm their way back in
even though most of us like to think
no we don't think like that anymore but
there's gut level stuff that still
happens
and not to go down a complete rabbit
hole tangent it's part of the reason
that the predatory trans narrative is
focused on trans women
i.e people assigned male at birth as
opposed to trans men
because they are rarely framed as
predatory because for transphobes who
view you as the gender you were assigned
at birth and not your actual gender
they are going to view
men
as being more dangerous
than women
and that may be an inherent thing in
terms of the angle they're coming at it
or it may be tying back again into the
idea that gay men specifically are
predatory
which a lot of
um the hardcore transphobes will
misidentify
trans women as being but i think there
might also be another element to this
because
there's another area of animation where
you see gay men a lot more often and i
bet
before i laid out the parameters for
what i wasn't counting
a lot of the examples you thought of
probably came from shows like
the simpsons
family guy
south park archer and in general
animation aimed at adults
and i think there's something to be said
there because
most of those depictions
are intended to be funny and lean very
very very heavily on stereotyping as a
society we seem to have a difficulty
still
depicting gay men
as something other than
some kind of stereotype
in the worst form that becomes the
predatory gay man stereotype but in the
more
theoretically innocuous form it becomes
the effeminate male you know the anus
has the second highest density of nerve
endings in the body of course they are
silly buns featuring the whalen smithers
dancers is it a crime to want to
brighten up my colonoscopy someone with
the lisp and the limp wrist and going oh
my god
oh no and i can't help but feel that a
combination of
lingering
discomfort from a
very harmful propaganda stereotype of
gay men
combined with the fact that
we tend to just stereotype gay men as a
culture
still in our entertainment i would say
much more than gay women actually you
can go back and look at my video where i
talked about the tomboy archetype where
masculine traits in women aren't really
viewed the same way as feminine traits
in men and therefore
manish quote unquote women
or
people with lesbian tendencies because
they're often conflated not always
correctly but still
that is not looked down on
the same way that effeminate men are and
if we're still hung up on the effeminate
male stereotype
that might be another reason that people
aren't comfortable with it
because if that's how you feel you have
to write them
i wouldn't really want to see that too
much either now again
i don't know the specific reasons and i
have a feeling that if you were to ask
any of these creators in person why
aren't there
more prominent or any prominent gay male
characters
they probably wouldn't have an answer
and i'm not trying to psychoanalyze
anybody i'm not trying to say that i've
unlocked the key to their ingrained
homophobia i have no idea
but i'm just saying that
i noticed something that seemed like a
thing
the amount of research that i was able
to do on my own
seemed to back up that it was a thing
and these are the reasons that
i'm coming up with as to why this might
be a thing
because this could not have happened by
accident for as much as a push as there
is for more lgbtqia plus representation
in media in general family media
specifically
this is weird
and i don't believe could have happened
devoid of some kind of reason
those are my thoughts on it what do you
think about anything i've talked about
any prominent examples i missed or you
want to bring up or anything you want to
counter like i said
i have an inkling as to why i think this
happens but i definitely don't have
definitive answers
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about them
like share subscribe i have a patreon
that is what supports this channel and
me in everything that i do any amount
you're able to give is of huge help but
don't sweat it too much the like share
subscribes help me out and i'm not going
to tell you what to do
so just come on back
next time you need a break
[Music]
and look at you
sticking around through the credits i
appreciate that well you know what
you're about to be treated to a whole
ton of names going by on the screen but
there's a few of them that i want to
give special attention to my special
thanks to bookworm jared boyce mj tracy
scrabbit vincent paul bartolucci kailyn
schwartz edelen
acker robin moore ross schultz and
shayla gourley if you want to hear me
mispronounce your name check out the
reward tiers on the patreon but for
right now
thanks so much
[Music]
now
[Music]
bye
[Music]